[Music]
Hannity now four months ESPN has faced
criticism for mixing liberal politics in
sports and now one of its hosts under
fire after she called President Trump a
white supremacist on September the 11th
Sports Center anchor Jamel Hill tweeted
quote Donald Trump is a white
supremacist who has largely surrounded
himself with other white supremacists
ESPN did issue a statement reading in
part the comments on Twitter from Jamel
Hill regarding the president do not
represent the position of ESPN now we
have addressed this with Jamel and she
recognizes her actions were
inappropriate no word if she will face
any disciplinary action from ESPN
earlier today White House press
secretary
Sarah Sanders responded this is what she
said I think that's one of the more
outrageous comments that anyone could
make and certainly something that I
think is a fireable offense by ESPN now
keep in mind only a few months ago Jamel
Hill defended a Colin Kaepernick tweet
and compareed quote runaway slave
patrols to police officers here now with
reaction Fox News contributor Tommy
Lehren psychology expert dr. Gina Loudon
and author attorney and political
liberal analyst Danielle McLaughlin all
right here's the the most amazing thing
and I can't take it anymore Danielle I
don't like that conservatives that the
present this is a lie and this is a
narrative that happens every two years
and every four years Republicans
conservatives the president are racist
sexist misogynistic you know what stop
lying about who we are because none of
us Tommy
dr. we're not racist nor is the
president nor the people around him and
I'm not saying for this woman to be
fired I'm saying that the left does this
every single election cycle and I've
never heard you say that for them to
knock it off I'll say it right now knock
it off I don't think it's fair for
anyone to be characterizing the
president that way I think that he gave
folks a little bit of red meat when it
with his on both sides comment in
Charlottesville which he did and
fairness walk back I will say though
that the idea that someone from the
White House podium is calling for the
firing of a private employees sort of
ridiculous can you imagine if Josh
earnest had said that
Donald Trump should have been fired for
the birth a conspiracy from The
Apprentice I mean I don't think that's
the place at the White House but I will
say conservatives Tommy you understand
this dr. Laden you understand this is
conservatives that are you know they say
one thing that is viewed over the line
and I'll fire them boycott them Tommy
well it's happened at ESPN before I
think we remember what happened to Curt
Schilling because of a post that he made
on Facebook again it was not on the
channel but his repercussions were far
more strict than the little talking to
that they gave the other host over at
ESPN now I can't help but think me
there's a little double standard going
and maybe ESPN really values diversity
but not so much diversity of opinion I
think that sounds more correct to me dr.
Loudon I and there's something wrong if
you're so willing to lie about other
people and I'm leaning on your
psychology background and your doctor
here yeah well there's definitely
something wrong with somebody who's
going around name-calling instead of
acting professional having said that she
has the right to see it but here's the
thing Shawn it's as if ESPN doesn't
realize that the Trump voter is their
audience you look at the NFL players you
look at the PGA the LPGA even very
frequent voters very conservative people
and those are your ESP and viewers and
so if they were going to do anything
with this particular commentator they
may want to think of replacing her just
because she is bashing their own
audience this is why the Levitan used to
lose and this is why conservatives tend
to build their numbers doctor well I
think we conservatives and far more
tolerant of freedom of speech expression
and thought I don't I don't do boycotts
and I don't call for firings imagine if
a conservative had said whatever similar
during the Obama years what would the
reaction be well there's always a
hypocrisy Shawn and we're used to it but
here's the good news you've watched the
decay of the leftist media over the last
eight to ten years as they continue to
spout their bigotry and to be so
intolerant and it left a really good
place for conservative media
conservative media is continuing to fill
those voids I like to say that every
time the left's about their mantra
another conservative gets their wings
and I really believe this is no
exception to that all right it's a
wonderful life
dr. Loudon Tommy I assume I don't know
for sure I know I've been a target of
all of this and fire Hannity and and
boycott Hannity and the left isn't
really tolerant I've seen horrible
things about you and dr. loud and myself
on social media and by these groups that
are funded seemingly from Soros type of
people well of course and I'm someone
that has gone to bat for what I believe
in and I've had to feel the
repercussions so I'm not somebody that
calls for boycotts or calls for firings
either and I would never do that I've
been very vocal about that but I will
say this kind of what dr. Gina was
talking about there the Trump voter is a
sports watcher and we're folks that
enjoy watching ESPN love watching the
commentary and I wouldn't call for a
boycott I wouldn't call for a firing but
I would just say to ESPN you know your
numbers are not gonna lie because we're
gonna start turning off the TV and
that's how we're gonna voice our opinion
that's how we're gonna use our freedom
of expression our freedom of speech so
watch out you might be losing a big
chunk of your audience and we're not
gonna feel bad for you when you do you
know and dannielle less less point to
you hasn't been helping the NFL with
Colin Kaepernick and all these players
seems that a lot of people are reacting
ratings are down from last year and last
year was not a good year for the NFL you
know I'm a free speech absolutist like
many conservatives even though I am NOT
a conservative and I think what is
happening what are your fellow liberals
or not well but maybe that's a
discussion for what offends me what I'm
being boycotted I'm defending your baby
I don't think that if you hear something
that you don't like you should call for
the firemen of that person right there
that's one of the foundational values of
this country and I don't like it when it
comes from the left or the right on
Colin Kaepernick like he has this free
speech right to protest to take a knee
which I personally think is actually a
very reverential thing to do obviously
when you're listening to the national
anthem people have the right to like it
to not like it his employers who are
private private entities have the right
to hire him or not and maybe this is the
free market talking but I will defend
his right to take that knee you know
your last breath it looks like the
Conservatives or the
ones that are open-minded the ones that
believe in freedom alright guys it's
good to see you all thank you for being
with us